what if the greatest predator that ever  existed was still alive today and living  in the depths of our ocean you have to  see it in IMAX and I really think you  need to see an IMAX 3d it is  extraordinary the first time I saw it in  that format it was like watching a whole  new movie you get immersed in the movie  you it is scarier it is bigger it is  cooler it just feels massive and when  you're dealing with a really big shark  it's good to have it really big it's a  little bit down he's kidding right  you're used to watching the movie like  this on your editing system or that's  nice too suddenly it's amazing and  perfect and what and so reason to go to  the movies if you have a chance to go to  the movies or see it on your phone call  it an IMAX movie chew on this you ugly  [Music]